i will be in the westwood one studios
once again for monday night football
between the bucks and the new york
football giants to wrap up week number
11. and joining us on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line is one of my favorite
humans on the planet in advance of this
game we appreciate him coming to the
phone in preparation heading into week
number 11 the
champion world champion head coach of
the tampa bay buccaneers bruce aryans
back here on the show how are you coach
i'm doing great rich how are you doing
buddy i'm better for talking to you uh
appreciate the call certainly uh
mid-season uh certainly mid-season um so
what would you say how would you term uh
the current state of your team
right now as you know the nfl media
folks are uh
you know we're all we're all
jibber-jabbering about what the bucks
are and who they are as i'm sure you
might know yeah
i mean
we we know who we are we're we're in a
good spot we uh
we did not play very well our last
outing and uh you turn the ball over
have penalties on the road you're gonna
get beat
so we've we think we've identified it
and we're really anxious to get playing
monday night what have you how how do
you identify that sort of stuff well
what's your process
when you look at the three games that we
lost they're all on the road
major penalties in critical areas
uh and we we lost turnover battle huge
and both and both of them and uh
let's correct it you know you just gotta
you gotta protect the ball better and we
need more takeaways uh
when we get our hands on interception we
to catch them and we dropped a couple in
that last game and and one before that
so you know just making plays that's all
it is but there's no panic uh we feel
very very confident about ourselves and
uh looking looking forward to the final
eight okay and so um when you uh say
what you say after a post game uh any
post game press conference coach i know
you you are
known for not sugarcoating anything um
calling your team quote unquote a very
dumb football team do you when those
words leave your mouth do you want to
grab them back or you're like no this is
what i'm just telling what that is no i
mean just telling the truth and we play
dumb football uh you know when when we
identify something and don't correct it
that's that's dumb
and uh
so hopefully we've got it corrected and
uh
because we had a great week's practice
somebody can't practice any better so
it's uh playing smarter faster football
on sundays okay
right and then yes that's right you got
you got this monday nighter coming up
against the giants um and uh tom brady
um he did not uh address much about his
two interceptions after the game with
the media uh you said it was on him it
wasn't the receivers it was on him how
do your conversations go after you say
something like that publicly
really it was only one because the other
one i'd still consider a fumble
you know jalen caught his perfect pass
jaden caught it and then lost it and it
threw up in the air so it goes as
interception but
um no it just it was a situation uh
just a high ball and uh so i to me i'm
not criticizing but i'm just answering
the question sure absolutely and i know
again we've been over this coverage
about you know your relationship with
tom and things like that and how how
well he has been performing uh in your
system as you're taking on the new york
giants here so i just figured i'd throw
that one out there and before we move on
to the game uh coach bruce erin's here
on the rich eisen show i'd love to give
you the floor on your reaction to the
tampa bay times uh story that uh antonio
brown's vaccination card may be fake
what's your what's your reaction to that
really to me there's no story uh yeah he
he says he's vaccinated and has a car
just like everybody else on our football
team and
you know there's a trust factor that
goes along with it and we did our due
diligence and saw everybody the league
will look into the matter and do their
due diligence but it's really no story
so have you called him into your office
and asked him again just point blank to
his face uh if he is in fact fully
vaccinated as his card says
coach no but you know somebody else did
and uh so i
have asked him i mean
when a guy gives me the card i mean i'm
good with it so
i don't know how this story got going
other than somebody wanted some money
bruce aryan's here on the rich eisen
show what is the challenge taking on a
giants team coming off of a bye
uh obviously you faced them uh last year
you you know how they've played you
tough daniel jones first career start
i'm sure still sticks in your craw uh in
your building what is that challenge for
you to take on the giants this week it's
huge looks like they're going to be
extremely healthy
um getting all their weapons back and
boy they got some weapons now
you know between tony and gallaudet and
they're getting a lot of john ross and
saquon's back it's a whole different
offense when saquon's back and and you
have to be you have to be ready for
daniel jones to pull it and run it all
the time so it's it's a big big when
they get all their players back and uh
you know look at that game they went
down to new orleans and beat new orleans
and that's that's not an easy job and uh
so defensively they're playing lights
out so uh that's a it's gonna be a heck
of a challenge i think they're one of
the better teams in the east and so you
you mentioned how it's a good week of
practice uh for you how often does that
actually translate
for you coach
i would have lost my paycheck so many
times saying well no way we're going to
lose i mean that washington week we had
the best week of practice ever coming
off the open date after new orleans lost
right and played an egg
so there are times where like fridays i
just threw them off the field before and
we went and played great so it it it
helps the coach's brain you know to
relax there at night and then maybe have
a cocktail oh we had a hell of a
practice we're gonna play good right and
so um
it's it's just something that is is just
anybody's guess sometimes as to how
somebody will show up on on a monday
night right and so um
how does one address something like that
i mean you've been there and done that
bruce yeah i mean you want to have a
consistent level of practice and we've
had i mean i never could ask our guys to
work harder
they work hard and
you know it's just a matter of when the
game is scheduled be on top of your game
and and make the plays that you can make
and
don't be the guy that
screws it up
bruce arians here on the rich eisen show
um your colleague in new orleans sean
payton went on my colleague dan
patrick's show and said that he thinks
that the taunting uh emphasis is being
over officiated right now
what is your thought on that subject
matter coach brucerion yeah i think it's
something that we have to get used to um
they're not going to change it and and
so you better get used to it
and like when they lowered the targeting
of tackling
players had to get used to it there were
a lot of fouls it's the same old thing
you know cheer with your teammates
celebrate with your teammates go look in
a camera or something but
you can't look at the other guy and talk
so it's just something you have to get
you have to get ready for right i know
you can't look at the other guy and talk
but somebody was was was flagged for
staring at the other guys the other
person's um sideline and the official
might not even have known he could have
been just looking at someone in the
crowd it just seems to me as you say not
changing it would you want it changed i
mean i understand that there's many
things that i would love to have it
changed but uh you know i think it's all
about sportsmanship and we're all for
sportsmanship of course
but
again when you throw it into the hands
of the official as a judgment call
there's how many different referees they
all have different judgment right no no
doubt about that i just find it again
just something where we're now asking
the players
you know in a highly emotional game you
know just like hey
when you're doing something you know
obviously you need to dial it back to
play within your own emotion where
you're not standing over somebody or
getting in somebody else's grill but to
sit here and have to worry about so much
in your job and these other players jobs
to just go in that direction it just
seems to me a waste of time to be very
honest with you coach
i'm i'm i'm wholeheartedly agreeing with
you rich so i'm preaching you're the
choir and i'm preaching right now yes
basically you're you're you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
yourself
okay very good so all right so where
where are you now in comparison to last
year we all remember thanksgiving
weekend
you know right years late years ahead
and uh you know for us we just got to
get healthy and stay healthy
and we'll probably start our
ninth or tenth different secondary uh in
this game so it's just a matter of
getting healthy and hopefully we'll have
two or three guys back
uh we don't know for sure yet but the
arrows are trending up and uh maybe get
some more back next week so who who
can if you don't mind um do you think we
see gronk monday if w what about what
about him
on monday yeah i think he had he had a
big workload today so a bunch we'll see
how he is tomorrow but uh his arrows
trending up sean murphy bunning is
trending up a little bit and
scotty miller would be just the game
time thing
uh
as far as
his availability and then carlton days
of davis is starting to make a nice move
uh we haven't activated him yet but he's
starting to look better okay and antonio
brown's starting to look better but it's
not for this week so you don't think ab
goes this week at all
on the football unless he really
surprises me in the next couple days
okay and then just last one again so
you're that that that tampa bay times
report you've just you you're just uh
letting the football uh you know the nfl
deal with that you you you think that
this card is
what's been handed to you is that i'm
just wondering what what would be
the punishment for something if it was
the other way around bruce i mean you're
really i don't i have no idea um i mean
that would be something from the league
i'm sure
but uh
it's a criminal offense so
um
if if there's any crime being made but
right
that's the first one i've heard of it
rich i really have no clue okay bruce
arians well again like because again
you're somebody who's obviously uh
uh a survivor uh you've gotten you've
gotten through a lot of your own health
scares and i just want to make sure that
everyone around you is
is safe you know what i'm saying i mean
tom moore is in his 80s and again i'm
not saying that what he did is anything
that's wrong i'm just genuinely
concerned that uh you know for your
well-being is one of the reasons why i
bring it up you know yeah i'm i'm with
you brother and we talk a lot about that
out there with the guys
and we're fortunate we have such a great
facility we're hardly ever inside
bruce aarons really appreciate your time
um thanks for doing it right in the
middle of the season right in the middle
of getting ready for a weekend i don't
take that for granted ever greatly
appreciate it
only for you brother i really appreciate
that very i i i send my best to you and
your family as you get going on uh for
week 11. thanks for the call
thank you brother you got that's bruce
aaron's everybody that's bruce arians
right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here